[Music]
you
your brothers chris and luke all actors
yes you're all actors which is the best
which is the best
well
i don't want to say it but i'd probably
go with me yeah
that's that's just arrogant
no that's the correct answer actually
you're here they're not comfortable
that's right i have a lot of brothers so
i would do the same thing how many
brothers you got i'm one of six really
i'm well one of six kids and i've got
are they all as big as you uh yeah
they're all big guys i got there are
four of us good and uh we were like a
street gang yeah
a really unintimidating street
we best way we went around town asking
people trivia questions yeah yeah you
joke your way out of a fight yeah
exactly how about you what you you and
your brothers were a lot of you you were
a street gang yeah were you a street
gang
were you close that way we were yeah my
brothers are my best friends i you know
i i wouldn't be be doing this job i
think if it wasn't for them and
my oldest brother luke got into acting
first and he did tv shows for a long
time in australia and and then chris got
into it and that was
kind of how i got into it that's cool
it's a it's become a family business
which is great yeah a little bit you did
uh i want to ask you we're going to get
on to paranoia in a second but you did
the expendables 2 since uh since i last
saw you i did yeah and you worked with
jean-claude van damme jean-claude van
damme and um i'm i'm just curious like
what's that expert say because you
actually had fight scenes with
jean-claude van damme all right yeah
that's how you have to say his name by
the way that's how we say it yeah you
can see everyone else and then you get
to hear says like jean-claude
he's uh he's just he's a scary person um
uh nice guy to work with but a scary
person
in what way just man being van damme and
you know he you're not sure if he's
gonna
have a conversation or just kick your
face in
he's like that no he's a really nice guy
i don't want to talk bad about him
because he might kill me yeah
well you just took care of it by saying
why you can't do it about him no he's a
good guy though we had a scene where uh
he
he he kicks me in the chest and um he
wasn't supposed to really hit me in the
chest and he uh we did a take and he did
a full
van damn
kick and it hit me right in the chest
and after the take wrong sort of came
over i was like you okay and i was like
yeah i'm good i'm you know no worries
and and then he came up he said it's
okay it's a controlled kick i was like
it's not that controlled because you hit
me
you hit me really hard yeah you kicked
me full in the chest but it was it was i
felt it was an honor to to receive that
kick
i think if you're going to get kicked by
someone van damme is probably a good
person to get kicked by
that's just so funny that like yeah he
can uh it's it's not his place to say
that you're okay that's what i'm
noticing it's not up to him to go like
he's fine yeah it's okay
he's fine
oh it's not your business to say that